there are few guarantees when it comes
to Deadpool he'll word vomit at the most
inappropriate times
he'll slay his enemies in ways once
thought to go against the laws of
physics and he'll make fun of anything
and everything around him including the
minds behind Marvel's biggest superhero
movie to date
Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds took the
opportunity to share a message from the
red and black antihero who had a few
words to say about people potentially
spoiling Deadpool - it only took fans a
few seconds to realize that the note was
mostly a parody of the Thanos demands
your silence initiative that Avengers
infinity war co-directors Joe and
Anthony Russo sparked up to stress the
importance of keeping plot details a
secret while the Russos addressed their
letter to the greatest fans in the world
Deadpool one-upped them by opening with
- the greatest fans in the whole
universe the similarities are undeniable
with phrases from the Russo's letter
popping up verbatim and Deadpool's note
but most of Deadpool's comments at a
ridiculous twist for example one of
these super secrets his team has been
hiding is the quote secret blend of 11
herbs and spices and Colonel Sanders
delicious mustache after telling people
not to say a word about the fund in the
movie Deadpool signed off with a hashtag
of his own hashtag Wade Wilson demands
your sister sorry stupid autocorrect
silence and now the Russo brothers have
something to say replying to Reynolds on
Twitter
the directors fired back with a photo of
a prop Infinity Gauntlet with its middle
finger raised captioned boom Reynolds
was quick to respond to the flip of the
bird though this time he took a higher
road than Deadpool whatever replying I
deserve that all things considered it's
safe to assume that the Russos aren't
actually angry and that the minds behind
the Deadpool sequel don't actually think
the Russos anti spoiler attitude is in
any way uncool how could they infinity
war has continued to smash records at
the box office
surpassing the 1 billion dollar
benchmark in record time and Deadpool
two first reactions stamp the sequel
film as being bigger better and more
brilliant than the original something
tells us both parties are too busy
basking in their respective successes to
be truly fired up thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]